hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
amid a pandemic and months of civil
unrest across the nation
can a divided country stomach a close
highly contested presidential election
result
fox news sunday host chris wallace
weighs in on the 2020 race
the possibility of not having a winner
declared on election night
and the controversy surrounding the girl
scouts tweeting congratulations to
supreme court justice
amy coney barrett and more americans
than
ever before can vote by mail this year
but with a blizzard of legal challenges
deadline extensions and conflicting
rules
local election administrators are
feeling the heat
former federal prosecutor and fox news
contributor andy mccarthy joins the
rundown
to break down some of the current
election-related legal fights
and what litigation we could see if key
battleground states become
too close to call plus commentary by fox
nation host
tom chalu the fox news rundown is a
daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm martha mccallum i'm bill hemmer i'm
shannon breme and this
is the fox news rundown
friday october 30th 2020 i'm chris
foster
with just a few days left to go in the
presidential campaign fox news sunday
host chris wallace says about the polls
and where
we are now with joe biden looking like
the favorite what's really remarkable is
with all of these
enormous events covid economy
george floyd race protest riots
ruth bader ginsburg this racism has
stayed remarkably stable
i'm lisa brady there have been a lot of
court fights over the 2020 election
already
and the u.s supreme court is letting
some of them linger until after
election day i really think they're
making a terrible mistake by
not just doing their job now and
upholding the state laws that apply
in each of these states to set the
election rule
and i'm tom chalu i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
if the presidential race is a marathon
we're down to the last couple hundred
yards
with four days left president trump has
been crisscrossing the country telling
supporters
it took generations to build the america
that we know and love
but if the radical left gained power it
would take them only a matter of months
to burn it down
tear it down or destroy it i'm the only
one standing between you and the
left-wing mob i hate to tell you there
aren't too many of us
joe biden says america needs a change a
president who is
not in it for himself but for others a
president
who doesn't divide us but unites us
president appeals not to the worst in us
but to the best
president who cares less about his tv
ratings
and more about the american people
president
looks not to settle scores but to find
solutions
record numbers of americans have voted
early with more ballots still rolling in
and huge turnout still expected on
election day
then maybe that night maybe we know who
the winner is
i mean i just think would be good for
the country because basically the only
way that happens
is that there's a decisive victory chris
wallace is the host of fox news sunday
honestly i think the country would
benefit from not being a 50-50 country
i i would hope both sides would feel
that way if there's a clear
uh victory by trump you know the
democrats have to say well
we lost and uh let's you know let's
mobilize for 2024
and conversely if it's a clear victory
for biden but you know
i think the worst thing if it happens
we'll cover it and we'll live with it
would be
a decision that's in dispute and and we
have to count every
uh absentee or mail-in vote and this
thing goes on for weeks and it ends up
in litigation
i don't think that helps anybody yeah i
mean we're gonna have to wait and see
how
i mean here's one night nightmare
scenario to look out for there's a
chance some ballots in pennsylvania
might not be counted that if they arrive
after election day they're being gonna
be
held separately in case there's a
successful legal challenge so we it
could come down to that
yeah i i frankly if you're going to vote
by mail
and you haven't already put your uh
ballot in the mailbox
you're a damn fool i mean everybody has
been alerted
to the possibility of that and why on
earth i mean i voted
weeks ago and and you know i i just
think it's it's
it's obvious so if i mean at this point
don't vote mail-in if you haven't voted
so far
go vote early or vote on election day
but mail in ballots now and frankly if
you even did it a couple of days ago
it's a big mistake yeah i mean even if
it does go well i wonder if this will be
one of the things that sticks
post covet i used a dropbox for the
first time it was at my convenience i
don't know why i'd ever go back maybe
maybe if it goes smoothly maybe we'll
all vote early from now on
yeah i mean i i did exactly the same
thing i got a ballot in the mail i
checked it off i went to an approved
incidentally
and let me just say something and this
is going to take a little political bias
i live in washington dc
there are official mailboxes there must
be
over a dozen all over the city in every
neighborhood
you know one or so and you know very
secure very clearly mark
this thing in texas where there is only
one drop box
in each county and counties in texas are
damn big and people have to drive for
over an hour to get to one
i mean that is just nonsense
well i don't know why that's necessarily
politically biased there are republicans
who might
not want to drive two hours or wait
until election day
either well because
early mail-in it just seems to have
become a democratic thing
and in-person voting seems to have
become a republican thing
and this seems to me to very much
discourage early voting i just
i just don't understand why there's any
legitimate reason
in an entire county that there would
only be one
mail inbox i know that it was it was
approved and in the courts and they've
they've agreed to it so it's not i guess
it was the texas supreme judicial court
but um it it really seems to me to be an
effort to discourage
voting yeah look if there is a big legal
fight over this i can't even imagine
what comes out on the other side in
terms of rancor or maybe even violence
from supporters of whoever loses and i
really like you just
hope it doesn't happen yeah um
you know we didn't have we didn't have
violence or
certainly not any measurable amount in
2000 we had plenty of rancor with the
bush v gore and what would happen in
florida and you know that came down
think about that how crazy it was
it came down to a single state and 537
votes i even remember
the margin for bush over gore in that
state
uh you just got you know and we're it's
so much more polarized country 20 years
later than we were back then
uh no it's the it's the last thing
anybody
should hope for is that is that this
comes down to another
bush v gore and goes to the supreme
court and imagine you know then you have
amy coney barrett who's just been
appointed and pushed through by a
republican senate look she's legitimate
and if it happens
but you talk about a thing that would
only uh
put you know an explosive flam
flammable on the political polarization
in this country
that would do it because you just hope
there's a clear
winner and a clear loser on election
night we have a peaceful transfer of
power or no transfer because
trump wins but just a clear decision by
the country
um in 2000
you didn't have what is now the supreme
court what i'm trying to say is no
longer seen as this
august grand a political body especially
by liberals there but there were
complaints when the girl scouts tweeted
congratulated
judge barrett just as a woman making it
to the court and they had to delete it
yeah and then actually i i think
uh you're overstating how apolitical the
court seemed then you know it was 5'4 it
went along party lines the five
republican appointed
justices voted uh to end the recount and
give the election to
bush before democratic appointed
justices voted to keep the recount going
uh you know which would have allowed
although there you know there's some
other recounts say that it wouldn't have
mattered anyway and that bush still won
but i mean that was seen as is quite
political and and you know i think
i talked to a couple of justices they
hated it they hated being
pushed into the middle they felt that
they had to do it but you know they
realized how much it was politicizing
the court and how much
it it damaged their image in the country
as being you know just applying the law
although they thought they had on both
sides um
you know i i promise you none of those
nine justices
want to have to vote on on who's going
to be the next president
in a normal year a more normal year we
might today be talking about the
economic numbers or whatever you believe
about hunter biden or the violence in
philadelphia this
none of it seems to matter i just can't
imagine it it's all about turnout there
are no more minds left to make up
now that's right i i do well except that
i do think covert
is still a huge issue and i do think
it's going to affect the vote and
probably not in in president trump's
favor because to the degree that you've
got
you know we're seeing big spikes and you
know i'm not saying that it's the
president's fault
but i i think to the degree that covet
is still out there
uh and the impact it's happening on the
economy and you see that there's been no
covet relief bill and almost eight
hundred thousand people
applied for health uh i mean for
unemployment benefits
none of that can be good news for the
president you know he wants the news to
be
as positive as it could and and you know
if kobe cases were going down and the
stock market
were going up and unemployment were
going down
those would all be good things none of
those are happening so i got to say the
fact set
would not seem to me to be particularly
favorable to the president and if he
wins
and i look there's a real chance he's
going to win i saw what happened in 2016
it'll be because of just people's
devotion to him
and trust in him and and lack of the
trust
in in joe biden i think it'll if he wins
it'll be a very personal victory
for donald trump because the issue set
out there
uh at the top of people's minds does not
favor the president
yeah i mean you see polls before there
are nominees you know
the president versus generic democrat
he's almost running against generic
democrat in this case
nothing against joe biden but um
you're right it's it's it's about his
personality
well and and frankly and you know i know
a lot of people are complaining about
the very leisurely campaign biden is
running i think some of that is on
purpose
because i think to the degree possible
they have tried to make it not a choice
i mean
trump wanted to make it a choice biden
versus trump
peyton wanted to make it a referendum
trump versus
trump and to the degree that he's been
able to lower his profile
uh you know maybe some of it is his age
some of it is caution about getting
the corona virus i think some of it is
very much wanting to have a low profile
so people are judging
trump against him you know against a
generic democrat
i mean what was meant to be all along as
an insult the sleepy joe thing
may be in his favor america may be ready
for a little sleepy
oh i absolutely and it's one of the
cases he made it's one of the cases
he and obama are making is just aren't
you tired of this
aren't you know what don't you would
just want to return to normal
uh now a lot of people would answer no
because they don't think normal
as it affected them and the power elite
telling them what to do
uh you know and and liberals saying you
know you can't
do this form of energy and you can't eat
this this food and you know whether it's
and you can't have this health insurance
they don't like that again in a normal
year i would ask you at this point to
maybe look back at the campaign compared
to others you've covered but you've
never covered one like this no incumbent
has ever had to deal with this kind of
health crisis
while running for re-election the only
one that in terms of just
all of the tumult would be 1968
uh you know we had the vietnam war uh we
had
lyndon johnson decide not to run for
reelection as late as march
of 68 you had two terrible
assassinations of
of martin luther king and then bobby
kennedy uh
but you know the the the huge
difference is obviously you know as bad
as the vietnam war
was i'm not i'm not taking an opinion on
the war
i'm saying that you know as disruptive
as it was it's nothing compared to
something in which
you know i mean it was over there it
wasn't here and we've had eight million
americans who have contracted the
disease
and everybody knows somebody who's
gotten it and almost a quarter million
people
have died from it and the huge economic
dislocation
and then the other thing is this huge
technological change
which is early voting and and you know
that's dramatically
going to increase but having said that
i'd make one last point
what's really remarkable is with all of
these
enormous events covid economy
george floyd race protest riots
ruth bader ginsburg this race has been
has stayed remarkably stable
biden has maintained a lead of about
seven
to ten eleven points throughout the
entire race
and and you know that's that's uh that
didn't happen in 68 that is really
odd that that things haven't changed and
it just seems people have locked in
and i don't think it's so much for biden
or for trump it's for trump or against
trump
that's really what the divide is and it
has been uh
throughout this entire year well fox
sunday host chris wallace i'll see you
on the other side unless we
aren't on the other side but the next
time we talk
we know who the president is that would
be my fondest wish
that america will have made a decision
and we will know whether donald trump
is uh going to serve another four years
or joe biden
is the new president-elect i just want
to see a result and a decisive result
and i you know and that that and hope
that we can all accept it
thanks chris thank you chris
this is tom chalu with your fox news
commentary coming up
president trump spent months warning of
possible fraud
from a widespread expansion of mail-in
voting during the pandemic
who's getting it who's sending it where
is it going where is it coming back
where is it coming from
his tweets about it prompting warning
labels and other penalties on social
media
but at the same time his campaign and
other republicans were busy in court
challenging voting rules in the name of
election integrity
as states started tweaking rules to
accommodate pandemic concerns
democrats including joe biden's running
mate kamala harris
accusing republicans of trying to make
it harder for people to vote
they know when we vote things
change they know when we vote we win
the results in court have been mixed in
fights on issues ranging from
signatures on absentee ballots to
whether states could send ballots to
eligible voters whether they requested
them or not
deadlines have faced multiple challenges
this week the u.s supreme court
blocked an effort in wisconsin to let
ballots received up to six days
after the election be counted but an
extended deadline
is being allowed in north carolina and
they're letting an extension stand
in pennsylvania but leaving open the
possibility of reconsidering that
after election day i think what's
happening here
is chief justice john roberts
is making what i would regard as a
perilous
bet andy mccarthy is a former federal
prosecutor and fox news contributor
and that is that the election will have
a clear-cut winner
that the states that have election law
disputes will turn out not to be
important to the outcome and therefore
that the court will ultimately not have
to intervene
in pennsylvania or north carolina which
is the other
state where the court issued a ruling
wednesday night the reason i think it's
a really perilous
thing for the court to do is by not
embracing the job that it has to do
to to straighten out what the rules are
before the election
the court has now guaranteed that if
it's called on
to rule after the election which is
highly likely
uh the court will now be in a position
of being perceived
not just deciding what the rules of the
election are to be but actually deciding
who wins the presidency which is
a situation i think or a position that
the court should not want to be in
that the country should not want the
court in uh and that really courts
um pardon the pun a catastrophe so i i
i really think they're making a terrible
mistake by
not just doing their job now and
upholding the state laws that apply
in each of these states to to set the
election rules
what is the biggest chance for i know
it's a broad question but what's the
biggest chance for a messy situation
here
is it this issue of a ballot deadline
how long a state has to receive
and count ballots after election day or
is it something like
potential fraud from you know expanded
mail and balloting
yeah so pennsylvania is the biggest
threat um the other
states i'm talking about wisconsin
and north carolina although the court
has already told wisconsin
they're not supposed to do this weirdly
even though they had just decided the
wisconsin case they refused to
do the same thing in the north carolina
case but the
idea of continuing the count for many
days
after the election and in north carolina
they're going to allow it to go on for
nine days
after the election that raises all kinds
of problems because you have to
continually monitor
how the counting is done but at least in
those states you can say
that they have a rule that says the
ballots have to be
postmarked by election day so
in theory no matter how long after the
deadline they come in
if they're if they're postmarked by
election day you know they count
and as long as that's monitored properly
it'll be messy if the election is close
because
you know all eyes will be on that
process but if the election isn't close
or even if it is you'll you at least
have a clear metric about what ballots
count and what don't they have to have a
clear
postmark or they won't count what the
judge has allowed to go on
in pennsylvania is very different not
only
has the judge allowed the the ballots to
be counted for
three additional days after the election
he has judicially uh ordered
that any ballot that either doesn't have
a postmark
or doesn't have a legible postmark
is to be deemed as if it were
submitted on or before election day
which means in theory
what could happen is if the election is
close you'll get the results start to be
announced on
november 3rd everyone will know
who won and by how much and
if you had people who were really
insidious what they could do
is pull together enough
unmarked unpostmarked ballots
for their own candidate to swing the
election in other words you know how
much you're
you're down by you get a bunch of
ballots that aren't postmarked
you do them after the election day and
as long as you get them in by the six
you can swing the result
that's the that i think is the real
dangerous problem
well in terms of monitoring the process
the president and his campaign have
talked about poll watchers
what's legal and what's not where that's
concerned
the truth of the matter is elections are
really conducted under state law
and there's not a lot that the federal
courts
can do about them there's not a lot that
the federal authorities can do
about them so you you know you let
people know that you're
out there and if there's anything
actionable on a federal level
uh you'll be all over it but the fact of
the matter is
it's really a state law thing and the
rules
are different in every state including
the rules about
you know who can be at the uh at the
polling stations and who can be
monitoring what about these
record-shattering
hours-long lines for early voting
i mean if on election day we still have
really long lines
what happens when the polls close and
there's still a long line
are those rules the same everywhere does
everyone get to vote
yeah well what traditionally happens uh
and i guess we can say traditionally
because we've had a few elections
uh in recent years where this situation
has come up
now and again is uh people will go to
court
and judges will issue orders
uh saying that the you know the the
polling place
has to remain open for x amount of time
and then you have a big dispute over a
does the court have the authority to do
that
when the state legislature has set the
date for
elections and b if the court does have
the authority to do that
what does the time extension mean and
what i mean by that is
let's say you extend the time from nine
to 11 o'clock at night
right to give an extra two hours does
that mean everybody has to be online by
nine o'clock and the
balloting ends at 11 or does it mean
that everybody who's online up until 11
has to be allowed to vote
so all these practical problems end up
coming up and what
what happens and i think what will
happen here
is there'll be an effort to segregate
the ballots
that are cast under any special
provisions that are made to react
to the long lines and then those ballots
will be kept separately from the other
ballots
and there'll be litigation about whether
they get counted or not because
you know these are the kind of things
that can't be decided right there and
then the night of the election
but when you get to court and the
challenges happen in the days after the
election
what they'll have to sort out is did the
court have the authority to do it and
which ballot should count
which ones won't but it could be a mess
well and depending on how close it is
uh those types of things could add up
to enough ballots to swing it the
ballots that were cast
after polls were supposed to close the
ballots that
are the subject of ongoing fights about
how many days states can count ballots
so you could see the various types of
litigation that you know that could go
on
if joe biden though let's say
hypothetically he's declared the winner
the trump campaign doesn't accept that
what would the legal
options for biden be at that point or
would it be a moot point
once and if congress certifies
the results i think it needs to be
stressed
that it's not up to a candidate to
accept the results of the election
the framers who were very smart
sophisticated people
would never have left it up to the
people who are in office
to decide whether they stay in office
our whole system
is based on balances of power and
divisions of authority
uh and the idea that you can never leave
too much power in any one set of hands
and one thing you can never do is leave
it up to the person who's an incumbent
official
whether they get to keep their job or
not so
whether the president accepts the result
or not whether biden accepts
the result or not um
there's going to be an election there
may be some disputes about the result of
the election but they will be sorted out
at the state
levels and eventually the states
and this will have to happen by december
14th by
federal statute the states will sort out
which candidate won that state's
electoral votes
the reason they'll have to do it by
december 14th is they will run the risk
of forfeiting the state's votes if they
don't do
that so they have a great incentive uh
to decide it
so whatever disputes there'll be will be
worked out
the states will choose electors no later
than december 14th it's really supposed
to be december 8th but there's no
in the law there's no enforcement
mechanism to force them to do it by
december 8th as long as they do it by
december 14th
the votes then go to the u.s congress
and by statute on january 6th at 1 pm
they count the votes
so whether the candidates accept the
result or not
really doesn't make any difference one
follow-up question though on this
december 14th
deadline do the courts abide by that i
mean if there are outstanding cases that
still haven't been decided they're still
duking it out in court
will the courts be like well you know
what we're out of time because
it's time for the for everything to be
finalized for december 14th
true but you know this is the beauty of
having a federal system
where the elections we don't have a
national election right we have 50 state
elections
so you can have a dysfunctional state
that can't decide
but the thing is congress is entitled to
set the deadlines for
the states to comply um
and the risk that they run if they don't
comply is that they forfeit their
votes so i don't see that happening i do
see a lot of ways that this could be
messy but i don't think that's
going to end up being one of them former
federal prosecutor and fox news
contributor andy mccarthy
thanks a lot for your time it's my
pleasure
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information
on your time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
as early voting continues across the
country americans are turning out by the
millions to cast their ballots some are
waiting for hours to do it
here in new york city voters have
finally gotten the chance to vote early
with this being the first presidential
election with that option
madison square garden is the home of the
new york knicks and venue for
countless major concerts neither of
which is happening right now due to
covet 19.
but that doesn't mean there aren't
people lining up to get in
this year the garden is an early voting
polling site
where hundreds have been standing in
long lines to cast ballots
last weekend on the first day of early
voting i put on my mask
and i went to ask voters how they felt
about it particularly the waiting part
some told me that it had taken an hour
and a half or more to make it to the
front door
but they were ready and i prepared my
schedule to make sure i could wait
so you like blocked out some time oh
yeah oh yeah yeah
brought a book sandwich so why was it
important for you to get out here today
on first day of early voting we just
know what we want like like we've
there was pretty much no doubt once
we've like got the polling information
we're like no we'll take care of it i
mean
this is uh we were talking about it on
the on the way in was just like
i i think it's important that
like a lot of effort has been done to
get voter turnout higher
and i know that like there is this
certain attitude uh
of like like certain people think it's
futile to vote certain people wonder if
it counts and i think
there's only like you know there is like
the first thing which is you don't know
until you try
but there's the other thing where um you
know even if you're pretty sure where
your state is going to go
like the the amount of turnout is also
important to show solidarity
right yeah it shows that like these
efforts like do things do mean things to
people and that like you know we are
listening and
and you know we have we have a uh with
something we can do and new yorkers
won't be stopped baby
do you normally get this excited about
voting no
not at all some people made it a festive
affair with singing
i wound my way around the long long
lines
and i wanted to talk to the last person
who walked up at the same time i did
his name was harvey what motivated you
to come out today on the first day
my friend from brooklyn she she she
hasn't that she's the first
she's a voter that doesn't vote very
often so
but in this election you got to vote
otherwise you can't complain
you can't complain anyhow it doesn't
help
what was the first president you voted
for
the first president i voted for just a
minute
let's see it was uh
[Music]
could be eisenhower i think
i didn't vote fives an hour
whoever ran on the democratic thing
harvey told me he's 86.
have you lived here all your life yes
i'm a provincial new yorker and you say
what does that mean
that means everything west of the hudson
is utah
and in a time of division in our country
the good news is
we can all do the same thing vote in new
york city tanya j powers
fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind i'm hearing a lot of
talk from public health officials who
seem to want to make the holidays
less fun this year but halloween
come on halloween's got to be all right
so i went to the cdc website and of
course it says protect yourself from
covert 19
this halloween and it has activities
listed in three different categories
low risk moderate risk and high risk
and it says you should avoid the high
risk category let's take a look at these
categories low risk okay a whole list of
things that
nobody would want to do including
virtual
halloween costume contests you know i'm
done with the virtual
no more zooms okay
here we go moderate risk go to an apple
orchard
where people use hand sanitizer before
touching the apples who writes these
things
i mean is it a brainstorming session
here's another moderate risk activity
it says go on a one-way walk through a
scary forest
with a mask on it sounds like a blast
okay what's in the high risk here it
says avoid these activities
number one on the list trick-or-treating
huh trick-or-treating
look it it's outdoors
it's young people the lowest risk
category
and everybody's wearing masks
guess it's not safe the kids should just
stay home i mean what's childhood anyway
it's just a temporary condition young
people these days they have
so much danger in their world people of
my generation
you know the only thing we had to worry
about when i was a kid on halloween
was somebody putting a deadly object
inside an apple i'm tom chalu
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa
just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it
on demand from fox news and amazon alexa
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes